the kb19 pandemic has shown us just how
devastating
a global cross-border threat can be
climate change and biodiversity loss are
no different
in fact they pose an even
greater existential threat
to the extent that we have to put
ourselves
on what might be called a war-like
footing
having myself had the opportunity of
consulting many of you over these past
18 months
i know you all carry a heavy burden
on your shoulders
and you do not need me
to tell you that the eyes and hopes
of the world are upon you
to act with all dispatch
and decisively
because time has quite literally run out
the recent ipcc report gave us a clear
diagnosis
of the scale of the problem
we know what we must do
with a growing global population
creating ever increasing demand on the
planet's
finite resources
we have to reduce emissions urgently
and take action to tackle the carbon
already in the atmosphere
including from coal-fired power stations
putting a value on carbon thus making
carbon capture solutions more economical
is therefore absolutely critical
similarly after billions of years of
evolution
nature is our best teacher
in this regard restoring natural capital
accelerating nature-based solutions
and leveraging the circular bioeconomy
will be vital to our efforts
as we tackle this crisis
our efforts cannot be a series of
independent initiatives running in
parallel
the scale
and scope of the threat we face
call for a global systems level solution
based on radically transforming our
current fossil fuel-based economy to one
that is genuinely renewable
and sustainable
so les zetterman my plea today is for
countries to come together to create the
environment that enables every sector of
industry to take the action required
we know this will take trillions not
billions of dollars
we also know that countries many of whom
are burdened
by growing levels of debt
simply cannot afford to go green
here we need a vast military-style
campaign to marshal the strength of the
global private sector
with trillions
at his disposal
far beyond global gdp
and with the greatest respect
beyond even the governments of the
world's leaders
it offers the only real prospect
of achieving fundamental economic
transition
so
how do we do it
first
how do we get the private sector all
pulling in the same direction
after nearly two years now of
consultation
ceos have told me that we need to bring
together
global industries to map out in very
practical terms
what it will take to make the transition
we know from the pandemic
that the private sector
can speed up timelines dramatically when
everyone agrees
on the urgency and the direction
so each sector needs a clear strategy to
speed up the process of getting
innovations to market
second
who pays and how
we need to align private investment
behind those behind these industries
strategies
to help finance the transition efforts
which means building the confidence of
investors
so that the financial risk is reduced
crucially investment is needed to help
transition from coal to clean energy
if we can develop
a pipeline of many more sustainable
and bankable projects
at a sufficient scale
it will attract greater investment
third
which switches do we flick to enable
these objectives
more than 300 of the world's leading
ceos and institutional investors
have told me that alongside
the promises countries have made their
nationally determined contributions
they need clear market signals agreed
globally
so that they have the confidence to
invest without the goal post suddenly
moving
this is the framework i've offered in
the terra carter road map created by my
stable markets initiative
with nearly 100
specific actions for acceleration
together we are working to drive
trillions of dollars in support of
transition across 10
of the most emitting and polluting
industries
they include energy agriculture
transportation health systems and
fashion
the reality of today's global supply
chains means that industry transition
will affect every country and every
producer in the world
there is absolutely no doubt in my mind
that the private sector is ready to play
its part
and to work with governments to find a
way forward
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
many of your countries i know are
already feeling the devastating impact
of climate change
through ever increasing droughts
mudslides floods hurricanes
cyclones and wildfires as you've just
seen on that terrifying film
any leader who has had to confront such
life-threatening challenges
knows that the cost of inaction is far
greater
than the cost of prevention
so i could only urge you as the world's
decision makers
to find practical ways of overcoming
differences
so we can all get down to work together
to rescue this precious planet
and save
the threatened future
of our young people